[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en france 24
en esta oportunidad nuestra invitada es
carla vizzotti ministra de salud de
argentina con quien hablamos acerca de
las nuevas medidas que se están
implementando en el país austral para
contener los contagios de ccoo y 19 y es
que el gobierno de argentina decidió que
desde esta semana y hasta el próximo 9
de julio el número de personas que
pueden ingresar al país por vía aérea se
reduce de 2000 a 600
nuestro corresponsal en buenos aires-
natalio cosoi le pregunto a la ministra
por qué este número de pasajeros y no
por ejemplo de 1.000 a 100 y qué tan
efectivas esta medida en un país como
argentina con fronteras terrestres tan
amplias donde es difícil garantizar los
ingresos y más allá de eso también el
control que pueda hacerse en los
aeropuertos escuchemos bueno ese es un
concepto muy muy relevante es imposible
cerrar la frontera quienes dicen que no
entre más nadie
digamos no conocen la realidad de
argentina la frontera terrestre que
tiene la circulación entre ciudades
vecinas donde la gente vive de un lado
baja del otro es por eso que el trabajo
que se hace en salida de frontera en los
puntos de entrada se autorizan puntos de
entrada muy específicos y cada
jurisdicción trabaja también en ese
sentido con migraciones y el ministerio
de seguridad los corredores seguros que
se han definido son seis aeropuertos de
aeroparque y san fernando y por supuesto
el puerto de buenos aires con algunas
empresas así que la mirada es
fundamentalmente teniendo en cuenta que
2000 era el máximo de personas que se
podía asegurar que se podían controlar
al ingreso y luego debían las
jurisdicciones poder hacer el control
cuando cuando estuvieran en su domicilio
las personas que hayan dado negativas
para justamente cumplir ese aislamiento
cuando se hizo el control de ese
aislamientos solamente seis de cada diez
personas habían cumplido por lo tanto lo
que se definió es que el control de las
jurisdicciones tenía cierta dificultad y
por eso se baja más el número de
personas para que las jurisdicciones
definan si los van a controlar más
intensamente en su domicilio si van a
definir el aislamiento en algún lugar
extra domiciliario y es por eso que se
llega a esos 600 con la posibilidad
siempre por supuesto de generar alguna
excepción siempre controlado por los
puntos por los corredores seguros y con
la circulación digamos de ingresos al
país por estos lugares sino por los
puntos terrestres y finalmente quisimos
saber porque si bien argentina pudo
contener la saturación del sistema de
salud todavía es uno de los países del
mundo con más casos y muertes por ccoo y
19 por cada millón de habitantes esto
fue lo que nos contó argentina ha hecho
un esfuerzo enorme en fortalecer el
sistema de salud se ha duplicado a nivel
global y algunos lugares están inclusive
triplicado el número de camas el número
de respiradores pero sobre todo tiene un
un equipo de salud personal de salud que
da una respuesta inmensa porque
realmente no solamente se ha capacitado
aprendido sino que también ha buscado
formas de que nuestro sistema de salud
pueda seguir dando respuestas inclusive
en la segunda ola que ha superado y por
mucho la primera y eso es algo que
todavía no hemos valorado suficiente en
argetina y seguramente lo valoraremos
con la perspectiva del tiempo nosotros
siempre analizamos esta situación y
argentinas tiene un número de casos
importantes un número de fallecidos
importantes es un país muy extenso que
tiene grandes aglomerados urbanos que
tiene una situación social y económica
que no es de ahora que no le permite a
la población no salir a trabajar hemos
tenido algunas dificultades en los
acuerdos políticos para que todos los
arcos políticos también puedan estimular
los cuidados y eso sin duda también ha
tenido impacto y de ninguna manera ha
sido el único factor
así que desde este punto de vista es
esperable en función de la extensión del
país los aglomerados urbanos y también
argentinas de un registro que es
sensible del número de casos y del
número de muertes que también con el
tiempo y la perspectiva se va a poder
comparar con análisis más técnicos de lo
que es exceso de mortalidad en países
que por ahí todavía no tienen un
registro del número de fallecidos por
millón de habitantes por hobbit pero
cuando se haga ese análisis se pueda ver
que en realidad fueron más lo cual a
nosotros no nos soluciona ningún
problema pero con esas comparaciones
siempre es importante analizarlo
así finalizamos este 5 minutos con la
ministra de salud de argentina carla
vizzotti realizada por nuestro
corresponsal en buenos aires natalio cos
hoy ustedes pueden continuar con más en
nuestra página web tras 24 puntos como
por supuesto aquí con nosotros quédense
esto es france24
[Música]